yeah welcome to this video playing black
against interracial mas a Syrian from
Turkey and let's see Carol con yes this
is a tricky little line with 95 what did
I recommend 96 is looks normal and what
now yeah probably just develop and not
think for ages so the best recipe and
curious c3
you don't to play the snow it's so
interesting
looks a bit slow but probably not
something I can really use can i play
Bishop at 50 is Bishop b5 so terrible
let's let's check maybe this is a lot
too great I thought I can play Queen B 6
Queen a for foxy aid picture bad for me
a minute to to Castle quickly so should
be okay what is he doing taking Knight
a5 but this looks really artificial yeah
now this this is annoying very annoying
threads to take now at ninety-seven hmm
maybe this one covering this happen and
still preparing see if I need to I need
to badly place if I've to make sure that
this pond is not constant liability
night IFIF I can place if I ever think
I'm playing book see sambrook cat5 this
is the idea if he captures on f6 I will
take with the pawn of course of course
yeah not sure I don't necessarily need
to take with the porn but it's probably
the right way to do to play
see why if you sit has this 97 idea
after that
hmm
can we do seven
I hope I'm threatening are threatening
now maybe it is the thread see if I've
now okay yeah yeah this is the tactical
way attacking c6 okay so let's consider
this wait wait Queen a6 Queen asics ram
it is before okay let's just take this
this is the principal move anyway
grabbing the pole so where to go maybe
here they can now play will be 1 because
of that five Bishop for once this piece
has got to use but okay I'm threatening
maybe to just I'm not threatening on c3
brooksie one what I'm threatening is a
bishop f8 actually getting out of the
capture and threatening night you form
this is some really a problem for him
you should buy valium
and it's a good news that is actually
spending some time so that I'm not so
far behind on the clock check
ok so P some make taking here
now just to take this can take on f6 but
it's not too terrible
from structural point a few blackest is
fine here default some and additional
weakness Jack 95 hello I'm he's got the
big back rank lucky 95 I forgot about
that takes rookie seven but a wondrous
hanging so it's not possible yeah yeah
it's a tricky position
threatening queen a one now simplifying
to a good ending Queenie one who k1
check Oh didn't see that coming but wait
wait wait wait Queen a one now why not
why not actually it doesn't have a check
anywhere so it takes rook Rooker you
want at the end up winning a piece
because the five hangs
yeah lucky probably I was bad worse at
some point here not at the end not the
last couple of moves but it looked I
looked ricki white reason hmm yeah it's
just a piece like this Jack Jack and
then I'm taking that the night I I
threatened this anyway so I think I'm
actually fine here because I've got the
somewhat better structure this default
porn is weak and asparagus week the
night is looking nice but it doesn't
have many squares I'm threatening
something like Bishop g6 and and King g7
here yep like us already out of the
woods he's some actually the computer
assessing this is rather much better for
black even but before I don't know it
looked it looked rather tricky I think
when he allowed me to take on be too I
was I was in good in good shape here I
don't know it looked slightly slightly
problematic the computer actually its
assets equal but I don't know it looks a
bit tricky to me like his may be able to
able to UM get some sort of blockade not
here here of course maybe maybe he
cannot but it looks looks trickier the
computer always lost my position I'm
surprised and you know I can take oh
here it wants to check with the other
night
check I'm now going to be fun
interesting with an equal position but
really this is equal I would have
thought that black should be okay here I
mean I mean I mean better now but he's
got he can play whoopsie one all right
yeah complicated game but he he lost the
thread at the end thanks for watching